hello and welcome to this intelligent
squared online debate can the internet
be made safe
now not that long ago as the internet
was just taking off and we were all
beguiled by its promise of democratizing
information the sharing of knowledge and
allowing every voice to be heard it
would have seemed mad to be asking how
we make the experience of logging on in
the safety of our own homes
less dangerous but here we are after
years of watching social media course
and public discourse make it common for
people to be threatened and bullied
daily for their beliefs spread fake news
and conspiracy theories and even lure
teenagers towards self-harm and suicide
for many the time has come to impose
some order on the digital wild west
with parliament currently grappling with
an online safety bill and tech companies
adapting and developing faster than it
takes to get any form of legislation to
even the committee stage in this country
is it even possible and if so what
should lead regulation and legislation
look like in a moment we're going to be
hearing from our distinguished panel of
speakers on what feels like an
incredibly urgent question
can the internet
be made safe if you'd like to join the
discussion by sending in questions for
our speakers please do in the second
half of this session we'll aim to get
through as many of them as possible so
please do start sending them in now you
can do that by typing a question in the
box
at the bottom of your screen and if you
don't want your name to be mentioned
then please click the anonymous button
before you press send
you can also tweet us by using the
hashtag iq2
now i'm delighted to introduce you to
our three brilliant speakers tonight
we're joined by margaret hodge veteran
labour mp who's represented barking in
dagenham since 1994.
she held a number of ministerial roles
in the last labour government with
portfolios across education work and
pensions business and crucially for
tonight's discussion culture media and
sport she also served as the chair of
the public accounts committee from 2010
to 2015 when she became known as the
scourge of tax avoiders
we're also joined tonight by jamie
bartlett director of the center for the
analysis of social media collaboration
between the university of sussex and the
think tank demos he's the author of the
dark net inside the digital underworld
radicals outsiders changing the world
and the people versus tech he's also a
fellow podcaster in 2019 he wrote and
presented the huge hit bbc series the
missing crypto queen if you haven't
heard it i think you should um it
exposed the biggest ever cryptocurrency
scandal and he's also now turning that
into a book which will be published in
june 2022
lastly tonight we're joined by david
babbs an online safety campaigner and
political strategist at clean up the
internet he was previously
the founding executive director of 38
degrees an organization that used
digital technology and social media to
involve millions of people in the
political process
welcome all now my first question to you
tonight is about online anonymity it's
one of the big debates around any new
legislation
and it's one of those things that i
think most of us will be wondering why
is it that when society has outlawed so
many things in the real world like hate
speech incitement to violence or rape
threats why are they allowed to go
completely unpunished online do we need
to take away online anonymity
to hold people accountable um jamie why
don't you go first
thanks man thank you very much everybody
and intelligent squad um i hate to be in
the position of sort of defending
the bad stuff on the internet because
i've also spent my whole career really
studying all the terrible things that
happened online so i'm not going to deny
it that that's it's terrible and we
should try and do something to make it
better but i think we want to
necessarily make the internet safe
because safe
on its own is not necessarily the
the sort of the
the role that we want the internet to
play in society could be safer but not
necessarily safe and anonymity in
particular
i don't think getting rid of that would
would actually solve the problems that
we're facing there's a couple of reasons
for that and i'll be brief on it because
we want to discuss it well the first
thing is an anonymity
is not the only reason it's a
contributing reason but i don't think
it's the only reason people do nasty
things online
um really famous study from the 90s the
first real study of online disinhibition
by a cyber psychologist an amazing job
back then called john sular who talked
about the online disinhibition effect
why are we meaner online than offline
anonymity the feeling of anonymities was
one of the things but it wasn't the only
one it was a lack of it was a distance
from people it was a lack of
contemporarity he said you know you you
wait hours before you reply to people
and anger bubbles up in your mind over
what they've said you don't have to
see them face to face getting kind of
like anonymity or getting rid of
animating wouldn't change those things
we'd still be behind a screen we'd still
be capable of being nasty and mean to
each other and indeed a lot of the
nastiness that we see online probably
comes from it comes from other parts of
the world places parts of the internet
that we never really be able to remove
the anonymity
so we'd end up sort of removing
anonymity from certain people but
leaving it for some of the people who do
some of the worst things unless we don't
want to have a free and open internet
anymore we want to block certain parts
of the internet off unless they follow
the rules on anonymity that we place
even in my own job you mentioned the
missing crypto queen i'm trying to
expose an enormous ponzi scheme
and to do that i would very often have
to go on social media or into forums
chat rooms
undercover using a fake name
any small move that would make it harder
for me to do that i wouldn't want to do
my job anymore i'd be too scared i
wouldn't want to be an investigative
journalist
um
and then you've got to think about how
that's just me and i've you know i'm
probably quite an unusual person in that
regard but there's so many other people
in some ways that want to go online and
express themselves and they're terrified
that if people found out who they were
they'd get bullied they'll get fired all
these all these like very very negative
side effects that you'd have from
removing anonymity where i think the
gains would actually be quite marginal
you'd still see a lot of hatred and
anger and bullying and all the terrible
things
that we see and finally
i still can't work out how we'd actually
do anything to get rid of it i still
can't figure out what the sort of the
technological solution to it would be
because one of my great worries is
handing more and more data over to
governments more and more data over to
tech platforms haven't we learned
over the last couple of years
how bad that is what that leads to and
the idea that the answer to our problems
is to give them more and more and more
about proving who we are that to me is a
no-go so
like i said
it's not that i i can see the problems i
know it does contribute to the problems
but i just don't think for the games we
would get for it it's worth the cost
margaret
well i think we are we
thanks manvine and i think we are going
to have an interesting debate can i
start by saying i think all of this
we'll see when david contributes but
i've worked and talked to david before
all of us want to protect anonymity
online what we want to tackle is
anonymous abuse and i make that
distinction we'll go on and and
and develop that
so i the first thing i want to say is
when this when
online first happened i was with jamie
100 i thought this is fantastic it
facilitates democratic participation it
allows us to hear voices that you could
never hear before and i really really
you know
warmly warmly supported i was an
advocate for it
and then um
i started having my own experience of it
and if i just say to you that
particularly when i fought
anti-semitism so i was fighting racism
in the labour party in a two-month
period
uh
when the uh report was published on
anti-semitism the labour party by the
ehrc
and then there were all the comings and
goings about jeremy corbyn's position in
that two-month period from october to
december i don't look at my own online
abuse anymore that an organization
monitors it for me community security
trust brilliant organization i had 90
000 mentions
90 000 in two months
uh of which the majority were abusive
and i just want to share with you then
i'm going to go on because it's not just
about it's clearly not about me but that
brought me into it the sort of things
that could go online so for example why
has half of one percent of our
population got so much power
rid us of this cancer that was uh jews
um i'm called a zionist [ __ ] as honest
a swastika is appropriate as israel as a
fascist state and then i'm going to read
one which might
uh
touch some sensibilities i want her to
feel despised it's what the [ __ ]
deserves i so hope somebody kills her i
really do
she's a lying deceitful hateful [ __ ]
who needs to be executed publicly so we
can watch and laugh at her the only
support she deserves is a handrail to
climb the gallows the vile [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
it's horrible
and it's not just that the sort of
racism that i have faced it's
really for children for young people we
know
that um
young people
particularly there's an increase in
suffering of mental health problems from
what they get there's been a massive
increase in self-harm and in
suicide and in sexual exploitation all
those issues now you can't actually say
that there's a uh uh uh
there's a correlation between the two
but you can you know it you can't sorry
you can't cause a causal
uh
relationship between the two but you can
say that there's a correlation between
the increase in those uh in those issues
and uh the growth of young people using
online then you have things like uh the
racism we saw that with the euro 2020
final where over 2000 uh abusive
messages posted there using the n-word
and
using monkey
enjoys as well then you've got
misinformation
the anti-vaxxers the people who talk
about uh
things like detail uh solving all the
problems of coronavirus then you've got
fraudulent uh all the fraudulent
advertisements that are on there that uh
uh get people into absolutely appalling
financial trouble and losing money and
you've got hate crimes so there's a
massive
massive massive it is a real problem
jamie and we have to tackle it you can't
just push it to one side and nobody is
pretending that tackling anonymous abuse
will get rid of all abuse of course it
won't it's not but it's an important i
think ingredient in it just talk a
little bit about public opinion most of
the public now think in a recent yougov
poll
four out of five 78
people favored requesting users of
platforms to disclose their real
identity so there is some support for
there is a great support for it among
the public and the other thing to talk
about which i only recognized when i
started getting involved in the issue is
actually the business model of the
platform
is based on there being a lot of abuse
traffic because the more
abuse that there is online the more
people watch it therefore the greater
the traffic therefore the more they can
uh uh get from their
from demands for advertising uh from
those who want to advertise on the
platform so the business model depends
on
allowing and not getting rid of online
abuse and i think that's really
important as to why should there be
government intervention this isn't
something that will resolve itself
because it's not in their interest to do
that
and can i just say something else which
i think is really important i don't know
you know here i was a great supporter
and promoter of anonymity then i start
getting this horrible stuff
and actually
what it is
what people try to do through anonymous
abuse is paint you as a vile awful
person
so for me i'm a paedophile i'm a tax
avoider i uh i have i've killed
palestinian children those are the sort
of things that are said about me online
and therefore they undermine
my credibility when i talk about
anything i could talk about royalty i
could talk about tax which i try to talk
about a lot but because i'm a horrible
person that can't be just
trusted uh there is no credibility in
what i say
so my own freedom to participate in a
democratic forum is therefore undermined
by the way that the abuse undermines me
personally and i think that's an
important thing to hold it in in pound
so i do support anonymity i
think it's hugely important for the sort
of issues that jamie talked about but
for victims of domestic violence
children who want to go on anonymous
you've been victims of child abuse i
think it's hugely important for
whistleblowers all of that what i want
to tackle and as we develop this evening
manvi and i hope it becomes clear what i
want to tackle is online abuse and i
think there is a way in which you can
maintain anonymity but start to tackle
that online abuse
well come steve in just a second uh
margaret you talked about credibility
there and how damaging it can be
um i wonder if before we move on you
could just sort of give people i know
you you have an organization that
filters some of the content that's
coming towards you but could you just
talk people through what it feels like
to be at the bottom of one of those
pylons for like the course you know over
the course of 24 hours what does it do
to a person
oh that's such a difficult question
because you have to learn
to understand that it's not the real me
that they're attacking and if i wasn't
able to do that to distance myself as
who i am you know what i care about what
i value what my friends think about what
my interests are if i couldn't do that i
think i'd be destroyed so i think that's
a technique i've learned in politics
they don't this isn't the real me that
this isn't
who i am that they're attacking it's
it's a sort of
you know it's a false
uh view of my persona
so that's one thing that the other thing
i would say to you is actually at the
height of this abuse i'm still getting
it i still every time i say anything i
get a torrent of abuse uh what it it
makes you very suspicious i think that's
the main thing is i'll walk into a room
and whereas i would have previously i'm
a quite outgoing friendly sort of person
being been confident there i tend to
look around me and think who's on my
side who's here to attack me and that's
something i never did before
and i do think twice about when i put
stuff on i do think i mean i have to you
have to be brave to do it randomly and
the only way
i i won't let them defeat me beat me but
equally i sort of do it by trying to say
it's not the me they're talking about
horrible thought it is and i didn't read
out to you some of the most awful vile
stuff that i get it's really it wasn't
the worst
i can't imagine how much worse it gets
um
david where do you stand on the question
of online anonymity
well i wouldn't ban it
um
but i would
suggest that there's a lot platforms
could be doing
to reduce its misuse and restrict the
ability of anonymous accounts to do harm
and
i think there are three obvious things
which all the platforms could be doing
um the first is offer all their users
the right to verify themselves if they
choose to do so most of the platforms
offer that to a sliver of their users um
some of us have got a blue tick by uh by
our twitter profiles or whatever but
that's a very elite
option at the moment i would offer
transparency to all users as to who has
chosen to verify and who hasn't so we
can make our own mind up about what that
says about the credibility of what what
they're saying we're always exhorting
people to
check the sources think critically about
the sources that we deprive them of that
key bit of information at the moment and
finally i would give each user more
choice and control over the extent to
which they
see content and interact with unverified
accounts so
though
knowing that um anonymous accounts are
more likely to be abusive and
that's different people have a different
appetite for
for taking that risk and you should give
those choices um
now
i don't think that's not a magic bullet
it wouldn't
solve all abuse um for some of the
reasons jamie has mentioned i think it
would make a huge difference um we've
we've studied to clean up the internet
that the way in which anonymity is
misused um
and it tends the difference between um
benign uses of anonymity and harmful
ones tend to center around two behaviors
which those proposals that i've just
outlined
would bear down on the first is abuse
abusive use of anonymity often it's it's
about unsolicited communication it's
communication that people don't want to
hear so give people that extra control
secondly it's about deception and in
authenticity it's not just that people
are hiding their identities it's that
they're deceiving people about who they
are so again make it more transparent
transparent to people but by making
those underpinning all of that by a
voluntary right to right to verify
you don't
shut out those legitimate uses people
can still build a following can still
engage online with
with the choice to remain anonymous it's
just clearer to people who is anonymous
and who isn't and everyone can make
their own mind up how much they want to
interact with those accounts now jamie
mentioned one study of
and he quite rightly highlighted that
anonymous isn't the only factor that
makes people nasty online but there's
been a lot of studies since and there's
a lot of evidence but it is a really
significant factor
recently uk internet users who'd
suffered abuse they're asked
to report what lev what level of that
came from anonymous accounts it was in
the 70s over 70
of
uk victims of online abuse reported that
coming from anonymous accounts another
study on twitter which you know random
controlled study where they gave some
users um anonymous twitter handles and
some
names ones and asked them to
engage in sexist content found not only
were the anonymous ones more likely to
retweet sexist jokes but they were then
more even more alarmingly likely to act
in a more sexist and discriminatory way
offline having the practice and that
behavior online
it has a real impact on how people
behave um and really well the way i
would frame this is that anonymity is a
risk factor and it's one which platforms
make choices about how they manage
through their design and
margaret touched on the the question of
the business model at the moment
platforms
aren't designing their approach to
anonymity with a view to maximizing
freedom of expression or safety they're
designing their platforms with a view to
maximizing their profits and
the the
the kind of measures that i'm suggesting
simply aren't incentivized by an
advertising business model which is
seeking to maximize attention and
maximize
engagement and maximize user numbers um
it introduces friction it sheds a bit of
light on how much they're accounting up
the account numbers that they can claim
to advertisers are inflated by
inauthentic accounts and this is where i
think we need
to not leave those kind of decisions in
the sole control of of these platforms
they're
too much of a public square but it to be
left to that and that's that's where
independent regulation the introduction
of some social obligations onto those
platforms to manage risk factors like
anonymity more responsibly that's that's
where we've got to get to which i'm not
saying it's easy but i think it is
possible
jamie um it
from david's analysis there it sounds
like it is having a more toxifying of
effect
um than than we previously thought
can we really manage with with no you
know with with complete anonymity now i
mean how do you sort of answer the the
sort of experiences that margaret's had
and the the abuse that people are facing
how do you how do you get around that
well i'm yeah
i'm always horrified to hear the sort of
abuse that
people like margaret get so i obviously
never want to defend that the question
is always
to me the extent to which a significant
difference would be made and the costs
that would come with that but david's
suggestions seem to be somewhere in the
middle so we're not talking about
banning it entirely or
you know preventing people who need to
remain anonymous online
on social media from doing that but
rather making it slightly easier for
people to see what they're doing and
who's anonymous and who's not and the
reason it matters is partly because we
we don't talk enough i don't think about
the positives that the the ability to be
anonymous at certain times does bring
we've got to talk as well about the
importance of of encouraging a free and
open internet all around the world
regimes are closing down on the idea of
a free and open internet and it always
comes down to the same thing make people
be forced online to show who they are to
give their documents over to have all of
their behavior monitored and we need to
not move in that direction so where we
can find some middle ground where it
helps people be slightly more critical
so you
encourage us users to work out what
different people are doing then i'm
definitely behind talking about that and
working out how that can operate
but
the for example the case of the racist
abuse of football players in
on twitter following euro 2020 the
overwhelming majority according to
twitter anyway of those accounts
were identified we should chat about
that
and so much of that abuse comes from
non-uk accounts so my question is always
how are we going to deal
with the overwhelming majority
or the the insignificant amount of
online abuse that doesn't come from this
country how do we stop that from
happening because there's a lot of
there's a lot of nodding of heads going
on in the other direction so i'm going
to go to
margaret first
okay i'm just to deal with a twitter
point i wrote to twitter and said could
i have the basis for their uh
uh their survey and they have refused to
share it with me i just don't think uh
you you can look at that as a legitimate
finding you know just to say to you jb
really and i'll share that whoops i'll
share that that correspondence uh with
you if that's helpful i don't actually
go along with david as he knows i don't
go along with david's solution
uh entirely although i'm trying to find
a different little way the reason i
don't go along with david's solution is
too cold first of all i don't i
i want to see i don't see why the only
way in which i can protect myself is to
say i'll only talk to people who aren't
anonymous who share their identity i
don't want that
i want to deal with an anonymous uh
people who you know i do want
whistleblowers to contact me i do want
victims of domestic violence and child
abuse to be able to contact me i don't
want to shut that off because they don't
do that and the second argument against
david's solution is that actually the
police i'm obviously in touch with the
police quite a lot mandan because of the
nature of the abuse i get and the police
say the worst thing you can do if you're
trying to identify a real threat to you
individually and i accept that that is
i mean it isn't as remote as we thought
as we saw with the tragic death of david
amos but the worst thing you can do is
cut off
the uh the traffic that you're getting
the online you've got to know so that
they can judge whether or not it's
serious so i don't agree with that let
me put forward my middle way which i
know david knows but i haven't shared
with jamie i think what we should do is
anybody who goes on a platform
should actually reveal their identity
not to the platform jamie not to the
platform um although they know all about
us because we know that from the
advertising that they throw at us all
the time but not to the platform to a
third party provider
uh
and it's perfectly technically feasible
uh we could use something like the banks
the banks already know 99 of people who
who
that would give you the adult population
that perfectly
so it's perfectly okay and you are
anonymous online i want everybody to be
anonymous and the only time when you
then uh
give up your right to anonymity i think
it's a right is if you engage in abuse
against other people and at that point
the police
in pursuing illegal ill illegal harm
online
or me wanting to pursue a civil uh uh a
civil case against somebody who abuses
me would have the right not to go to the
platform but the platform would then get
it from the third party so the platform
hasn't got the details the third party
has and i have the right to access that
or the police do uh if and when there's
uh if they're harmful abuse and link to
that two other things that have to go
with it at the moment that the law in
relation to online harms is too limited
and actually nadine doris made a
statement over the weekend where she
tightened up and introduced three new
uh uh she's going to introduce on the
online harms bill three new offenses
which would make it much tougher and
would make it much more difficult for
example to have revenge porn to have a
promotion of suicide to have actually
sexual exploitation people smuggling all
that stuff would be then
uh created as a criminal offense and
that's really important so i really
welcome what she did i should say man
that this debate is not a partisan
debate
that you know i'm working on a
cross-party uh basis with other people
and then the final thing i want to say
is i think because of the way this this
is a business model the online platforms
no good finding them zillions because
that just becomes a business cost
against their business uh against their
business and they're making so much
money they you know even that what we're
talking about wouldn't hurt them harm
them that much i think you have to get
director liability and responsibility
into uh the legal framework that we
would do for for uh uh
monitoring and regulating online harms
uh and i do this for my tax
you know my tax justice work that is no
good getting at the corporations that
doesn't change no good getting at the
banks no good getting at any of these
people because that simply doesn't
change their behavior if you introduce
individual director liability where they
break the law so with these new offenses
where they don't take stuff off that
could do all this massive damage then
they are individually liable so i would
it's a different solution to david's but
i think it's the only one that is
sustainable but i accept that jamie i
want to protect
anonymity but if you're going to do that
you have to deal with the online arms
david you've had your solution
questioned another one posed what do you
make of it
well i i i know margaret but you you you
say that they could be complementary are
different solutions um
one doesn't necessarily preclude the
other but i i think that the thing that
we would need to ensure
the advantage of a voluntary system
based on the rights to verify
is that
you've got that important backstop that
if someone for whatever reason can't
can't
access the process
of verification
whatever that process is um they they
are still able to access um
the internet and that means of
expression and
we would
with our
voluntarist approach still lay a heavy
emphasis on the importance of
accessibility in terms of verification
so not relying on too narrow a range of
documents offering a range of options
making sure that it's accessible but
it's privacy respecting etc but having
that
extra get safeguards that no one no one
is precluded from being able to access
the platforms because
because of an inability or a reluctance
to verify but that could be a legitimate
one it would need to be something that
we need to address with with margaret's
solution i'm not saying it can't be done
but it would be that extra barrier i
wanted to come back for a minute to
jamie highlighting that twitter claim
about um
online online abuse directed at
footballers after the euros because
after margaret
contacted them and my organization
contacted them as well seeking more
information
they then offered some answers to the
home affairs select committee and i was
in some correspondence with some members
of the dcms select committee and here's
where i think we've got to with that
claim i think in order to make the claim
which twitter made that 99
of the abuse directed of england
footballers was not anonymous they
adopted a definition of not anonymous
which would include an account called
mickey mouse
registered with the email address mickey
mouse is not my real name at gmail.com
because they would say that that person
has provided a name and provided an
email address um and
i mean you know there isn't a statutory
definition of anonymity but i think that
would
be it's quite a sporty definition by
most of our standards i think if you're
being charitable and i think this is a
really good example it was a very
helpful thing for twitter to do in some
ways because it demonstrates that at the
moment these kind of choices and these
decisions are being taken by platforms
with commercial interests and you know
with a tendency to put spin on it and
that's
that's where open opening these
processes and these kind of claims up
being giving independent
experts access to the data to verify
these kind of claims but also
giving into bringing independent
scrutiny to the design decisions they
make around on these kind of issues
whether that's on anonymity or on the
design of their algorithms on their
approach to content moderation i think
they've shown many times that their
agenda should not be able to drive all
those decisions because when it does
they
they tell fibs to put it bluntly
jamie do you want to come back on that
before we move on to yeah i mean
it's a hard one to
do
to resolve because all of us think well
we like the idea of anonymity being used
where it has its beneficial uses
um but we just want to cut out the bad
bits of that
but then every technological solution
you come to i don't think fully uh
permits that i think in the end that you
always have to accept some of the bad
with some of the good
so
margaret's example
maybe there is a technological way
around this but i just can't see how
everyone would have to just to go onto
like telegraph comments or youtube
comments or twitter or facebook i'm
going to have to hand over
some id some document i don't know what
it would be to some third-party database
that would hold it there securely i mean
it just gives me the cree i really
terrifies me that i'd have to do that
and as for family members of mine that
would have to do that they just wouldn't
bother going online because they
wouldn't know how to do it and so
what would invariably happen and you
know this does always happen that
database in the end will probably get
hacked
because they all seem to in the end and
then all of that data that links
individual people can you imagine what
that would do
if that database was hacked and then
every individual anonymous accounts real
identity
yeah jamie you use paypal if you don't
do paypal online you give it anyway and
this whole thing
i think there's a sort of you know they
know all about us for goodness sake you
know from everything you get online or
when you sort of you know uh you they
know absolutely you do anything online
and immediately you get inundated with
advertising that reflects that
particular purchase you've made or the
particular person
a person you've written to they know
what about you this idea that somehow
there's grand anonymity and i would not
give it to facebook i wouldn't give it
to twitter i would give it to a third
party not ideal
none of these things are 100 fail-safe
but you just can't ignore the growing
abuse you can't do it it was you know i
just say that i'm not saying this from a
personal problem i'm not ignoring it
margaret i think the mistake is that
when i say i'm worried about drifting
towards more and more trying to make
people verify their identities online
not seeing the benefits of
the anonymity brings
i'm not saying we should do nothing i'm
saying like focusing on that might not
be the way to do it so for me
i think a couple of things one is
definitely the business model of the big
tech platforms i think we probably all
agreed on that because in a sense that
it's almost the opposite
the the the difficulty we have in
staying anonymous online is driving so
much anger and hate because people are
being constantly targeted i don't think
with hateful content but with sort of
constantly self-reinforcing personalized
targeted emotion-filled content
that they're i think is getting people
more and more like turning the sort of
the outrage machine of the internet on
and that's based on get them sort of
being able to target us better and
better and if we're a bit more anonymous
online they wouldn't be able to do that
quite so well so we probably wouldn't
have quite as much anger and outrage so
if we can start dealing with the
business model of the tech platforms i
think that is one way of doing it but
that's a different way of sort of
targeting the problem and without a
doubt
like to me the policing of all of this
is appalling because as you've rightly
said a lot of times the hate the really
serious hate because i think
knock about online and anger frustration
heated debates we've got to allow that
to exist because that's part of living
in a free society the really nasty stuff
a lot of the time and you'll know it too
margaret the problem is the police's
inability and often it's a resource
and a lack of resource and a lack of
technical know-how to actually try to
find the people behind this a lot of
times you can find people behind
anonymous accounts but the police won't
do it for lots and lots of reasons and
by the way no one's dealt with my issue
of overseas abuse because because there
is no obvious answer to that but it is a
really important part of this to me
can i just come back to your one thing
on the free speech question because i
think that's often brought i don't want
to i really did believe that
you know online would support free
speech but women you know and women of
color
who are the ones most much most likely
to be targeted uh through uh online
abuse their freedom to participate is
inhibited by their fear of receiving
abuse
and that is really important and then
the other thing which we haven't talked
about is uh young people and
you know them if there is a real
correlation
a causal relationship between you know
uh
suicide sites and on harm and uh
self-harm sites
and just generally mental health issues
that arise we can't ignore that i can
see the benefits and i think any
solution is is never going to be 100
perfect but you can't ignore the harm to
young people and children yes but i
don't think those things are caused by
well
for example
we don't know i'm going to i'm going to
move you all on now actually just
because we're getting so many questions
in from
the audience and i really want to try
and get through as many as possible um
so
starting with a question i'm glad
nobody's been decided to use the
anonymous button tonight um it's a
question from jimmy saying what do the
speakers think explains the failure of
the tech giants to police their users
properly
is it greed or lassitude
and similarly i mean i want you to take
them perhaps both together um just for
timing reasons we've got a question from
rose which talks about the effect uh
what effect do you think facebook's
moderators are having on cleaning up
facebook so you know we've been talking
about government legislation so far can
we leave it to the tech companies are
they doing enough
is is it working um
jamie should we start with you well i
think generally content moderation as a
sort of a part of the business model of
the tech platforms
certainly until recently was not taken
seriously it's outsourced to
the philippines and elsewhere it's very
low paid work
it's very difficult work there's not the
sort of support that's in place i think
um david will probably know more about
specifics but i think it's improved over
the last three five years but for a long
time it was seen as a kind of
sort of not particularly important part
of the core business model and so as a
result and this is especially true
outside english language um sort of
parts of the platform
there just wasn't enough people that
were doing that work and they weren't
well trained they weren't well they
weren't necessarily
well paid their role wasn't seen as
being particularly significant they
often weren't employed directly by the
company but through agencies so i think
like
as as these as these platforms become
more and more
publishers in a sense and so certainly
in their
sort of social political
role
they're going to have to just keep
investing more and more time and
training and resources into the role of
content moderation you see where there
is this abuse i'm not saying it
shouldn't be removed i'm saying it
should be yeah there should be more
effort on focused and targeted ways to
remove it when it seems so that's one
that is that i mean that is one fairly
obvious thing relatively uncontroversial
i think and jamie would you be happy
leaving it to the tech platforms alone
to police themselves given your stance
on anonymity and the interference of
government
um
yeah i mean there are
nice would you think i sort of have an
answer for this
having talked about i saw i saw a veer
between thinking i'm really worried
about government and then the next day i
think i'm really worried about the tech
platforms
so i think i think on the heart i think
on the whole it's all watch how well
they do
have systems to monitor how well they do
and when they're not doing well enough
you uh
you look where you intervene
david there's no there's not one answer
to that
it's it's fair to say that uh
the platforms have increased their
investment in content moderation um
and
that
that's probably a positive um jamie
mentioned that it's not
that that's that's a problem outside
english language um
with the noticeable
kind of outlier of the german language
where um
germany has brought in
uh more regulation and that prompted
greater investment lo and behold in
german language content moderation um
there are there are downsides to content
moderation as a solution one is that
it's it's really tough work um and
you know we should certainly support
efforts to get content moderators better
working conditions proper psychological
support etc but it's it's always going
to be tough work um
it's it's it's also i think
tricky you know it's always going to
raise kind of challenges in terms of
where you draw lines and how you balance
freedom of expression etc and that's why
i i would advocate that alongside
thinking about content moderation we do
also think about what else about the
design of a platform could kind of
tackle
the need for moderation in the first
place in terms of what what about these
platforms brings out the best or the
worst in people um jamie mentioned the
kind of aspects of the business model
that
you know thrive on generating outrage
and polarization rather than promoting
understanding um i think online
disinhibition of which probably this
the facts are the ingredient within
online distribution that we are most
equipped to tackle is anonymity is
another such factor where we
that yes there are trade-offs here in
all these design choices but
are the platforms on their own
with their incentives their ideological
hinterlands you know these are you know
libertarian companies from you know a
much more libertarian country than ours
are they
the best sole decision makers of where
to land those trade-offs how to make
those design choices um
i think
probably
there was a there was a point where you
could say maybe
um but you know look at the internet
we've ended up with um
yes
our government has all kinds of flaws
has all kinds of challenges
catching up with with the digital age
but
we need some so
to introduce social considerations into
this design and i can't see where that
can come from it's not from some form of
democratically mandated regulation
margaret um how do you think the tech
platforms are doing
um i'm much tougher
i think uh they these algorithms i agree
with david they could change the
algorithms tomorrow if they chose to
and that would uh
uh
you know support getting a lot of this
uh you know particularly don't think
just about the abuse that people like
and i get think about the stuff that
kids get you know and and the links in
there to
uh a child protect you know all the
stuff that we want to protect children
so you know the links that that
encourage them to get onto suicide sites
or self-harm sites or stuff that you
know impacts on their mental health i
think all that and then also think about
the anti-vaccine stuff you know where
actually when there was finding enough
pressure they did a little bit more than
the platforms so i think they
deliberately don't
manage their algorithms and i think they
are totally motivated by greed and i
think in those circumstances um uh you
have to have intervention i i'm not you
know
uh ofcom would be the agency that would
be responsible so it'd be an arms length
agency from government itself so it
would be mp bobbing up and down saying
get rid of this get rid of that it would
be regulated by a a a a an agency
distant from government but if you leave
it they've had long enough they've had
long enough and they have simply failed
and they fail because they make money on
the back of it
well margaret you mentioned the age
problem there and how we've seen seen
teenagers being um you know sort of
often lured into self-harm suicide all
sorts of awful corners of the internet
i'm going to try and sneak in another
very quick question before we move on to
the next one this is from sergio aguero
who's asking why has the government
removed age
verification from the online safety bill
a lot of us are asking that question and
uh it's an issue that we're also
campaigning on to get back into the bill
so i agree
and jamie where do you stand on that i
mean sort of the the downside of having
a completely open internet is that an
awful lot of children are seeing stuff
which is
possibly sort of influencing them to
take their own lives or at least sort of
even hardcore porn which is you know
it's changing
the way people are growing up it's
changing society where do you stand on
that
uh on on what age verification age
verification i mean would you would you
put in some regulation right now
yeah
i'm not sure it's another one where i
don't really have another fully fleshed
out answer because i've never worked out
how you'd be able to
build the correct sort of technology to
make that actually work and function
smoothly so maybe i mean again it's one
of those tricky ones that if you can if
you can create the technology to make it
work really effectively then fine one of
the biggest problems that i had and it's
actually the reason i wrote the book
about the darkness in the first place
was just how little parents monitored
what their kids ever did online even had
this remotest idea what sort of
platforms they were going on to
parents own sort of internet literacy in
terms of being able to put on their own
firewalls they're just being have like
rings being run around them by the kids
and i mean if you can't even
so any age verification system that's
put into place they're gonna come
they're going to come up with quite
simple ways to get around it if the
parents themselves aren't sort of
up to speed with how how to make it work
so the first thing on all of this was
always like how can parents actually
take more responsibility and sort of
understand a bit better jamie don't
blame the parents don't blame them
margaret it's embarrassing
no i'm sorry
i'm not getting anything
to this margaret i'm not blaming parents
i'm not blaming parish entirely
but i think when i was the way that i
always used to think about it when i
used to get up to naughty things when i
was younger
my parents kind of could understand what
they were because they were more or less
the same things that they used to do now
it's a completely different world and i
know how hard that is but to me it's a
bit of a derogation of duty when i hear
parents say all the time all the kids
are upstairs on the internet i've got no
idea what they're doing and i think why
don't you try to learn why don't you
spend some time on these platforms
i think most parents do try
yeah no no most parents do try but if
you really think you'd have said 24 7
looking after you
and let me just say let me just say
something else in response to what
you've said i think for you the
the best is the enemy of the good you
know none of these solutions that we are
proposing are totally fail safe you know
whether it's age verification all that
stuff it's not going to be 100 failsafe
but it's better than where we are and
it's such a fast-changing environment no
doubt the things that i'm proposing
today will probably be out of date in
three four five years time we've just
got to recognize you've just got to
continuously look at
how you respond but i do think for you
jb the best is the enemy of the good but
margaret can i just say already we agree
like tech platform business model
big problem inability of the police to
actually tackle the cases that they find
big problem i also agree with with some
of david's suggestions about can you
make it easier for users to see to offer
the option of self-verification now so
there are actually a lot of things where
i totally agree there are things we can
do there are things we can do to improve
it i'm not saying just leave it as it is
david very quickly do you have a any
thoughts on age verification yeah i i
think history will probably not judge us
very kindly when it looks at this time
when we thought
we were comfortable with exposing
the majority of children over 10 to
hardcore pornography that just you know
something needs adjusting there and i
think one of the challenges that the
parents i speak to feel is that on the
one hand they do want to protect their
kids from this stuff they also recognize
all the benefits of the internet and
what we really need to be striving for
is to give children a right to access a
version of the internet that is safe for
them i think the age verification
solutions do exist they're not perfect
but there are a range of companies that
have developed secure privacy respecting
ways to verify age um
parliament can specify in the online
safety bill the minimum standards for
those and mandate companies to use them
and i think look look i was i was a
proud owner of a fake id when i was like
15 16 i'm pretending to be a member of
leicester university students union um
obviously people will get around these
things but one of the things that child
psychologists tell us which i think is
really important on this is that
when a child is in a space that is if if
a child accesses a space but they know
they've gone through the rigmarole
of evading a system that's designed to
keep them out that in itself is useful
it means they know that they're
somewhere they shouldn't be that sets a
boundary that in itself is a protection
measure so i think margaret's right we
shouldn't let the perfect be the enemy
of the good here of course whatever
measure we measures we come up with some
people will circumvent but the the even
the signal of an effort as well as it
protecting a lot of people absolutely it
just at least tells children this is
stuff you shouldn't be seeing
now i want to move on to another
question from the audience which covers
a subject we haven't talked about enough
tonight really and it's misinformation
is a much greater threat to our society
than online abuse can the panel give us
a few suggestions on how we can deal
with it
um
jamie
well
as you can tell i don't have answers to
a lot of these problems
but this is the downside of having a
completely democratic
internet
yeah i think misinformation we might
find is probably slightly harder to work
out how to deal with um
and certainly i i really don't think
that online anonymity is is the cause of
misinformation and if you look online at
the things that you would consider to be
you know
dangerously uh inaccurate a lot of it
comes from very very famous verified
public people
so this is going to be this is going to
be this is a this is a much trickier
much trickier problem
the only thing and it's really i know
it's going to sound really sort of
really basic and boring but i'm
i've only ever been able to sort of
see that the solution has to lie in a in
a change to how we teach
um information literacy in schools now
for what for a while it was seen that
what we need to do is teach critical
thinking yeah that's fine but that has
its problems as well
but some additional digital literacy is
added to that how do google's algorithms
work and how to how does facebook's
business model work and all the rest of
it and i think that's all well and good
and we do need to teach all of that but
i think something slightly deeper is
going on here um
a lot of the
uh
sort of
the reasons why people believe certain
things that we might find troubling
or end up spreading information that
isn't accurate is because of our own
cognitive biases it's not just because
the digital platforms are feeding us
nonsense it's because we also have a
bias in ourselves to want to read
information that we already agree with
and so on and so i think any any
education-based solution to this where
we sort of try to improve media literacy
hash will also include quite a lot about
human psychology and individual
cognitive biases and sort of the
anchoring effect and the echo chamber
effect and all these other sort of
sociological and psychological biases
that we haven't i still don't think we
quite teach that well enough in school
so that's what i'm sort of i suppose
more hopeful about because i think that
is something we we really can change
david
well i i wouldn't discount jamie the
role that anonymity plays plays in this
information just to give you one example
there was a study of um muslim
candidates in the last u.s congressional
elections which kind of picked out
the different role that different kinds
of accounts played in um
in a spreading islamophobic
disinformation about those candidates
and you're right jamie but some of it
mostly originators of a lot of that
information weren't when names were
named accounts were real people but only
11 of the top 40 what they termed
amplifier accounts the accounts that
then pumped that stuff out and got got
it to a wider audience were authentic um
and i think most
organized disinformation operations use
huge numbers of
sock puppet accounts um
bot accounts inauthentic accounts to
trick both humans and platforms
algorithms that extreme ideas false
ideas are more mainstream than they
really are um
now you see that as well with fraud and
scams so the the commercial equivalence
is the fake product review like there's
no one magic bullet anonymity isn't the
soul factor just but design factors that
can make play a big role just to give
you one little example positive one from
twitter they introduced a prompt before
someone shares a link on twitter asking
them if they read read the thing first
that appears to have had quite a
significant dampening effect on the
spread of this information those are the
but you know that's the kind of thing
that happens thanks to pressure it's not
something which their business model
incentivizes
i agree as well all this stuff about
education is important um but that's a
long term thing and i don't think we can
place all our hope in that
margaret what do we do about this
information um just one thing i wanted
to say i mean we talked jamie talked
about the global nature of the internet
and uh the alleged
uh russian interference in for example
the brexit vote here in the uk and the
u.s presidential
elections is an example of miss and you
know alleged she says quickly alleged
missing misinformation being uh uh
deployed to impact in a really insidious
way on on uh outcomes of uh important uh
uh democratic occasions both in uh the
usa and here so
you know anonymity
allegedly supports that so that's the
first thing the second thing is i
completely agree with jamie about
education completely agree with that and
i think we uh again that ought to be uh
we ought to do what we can and i'm
conscious actually that i haven't talked
enough about that and i take that away
as a sort of learning point from this
debate and the third thing i want you to
say this is one thing that dean doris
has done a good thing about because she
has suggested that we would should
introduce a new offense
of deliberately sending a false message
and that introducing that as a criminal
offense
i think will support if the police
resource sufficiently and i accept that
point but will support
um again
uh bearing down
on where miss won't get rid of it all
it'll help us to bear down on
misinformation and if we were only to do
that with direct liability which i
talked about earlier so you actually
create a liability
on um
the directors themselves to to take off
their platform uh deliberate
misinformation i think you would have
the beginnings of
an a coordinated attempt to bear down
but not completely get rid of in
misinformation
i'm afraid we are
really out of time we've got some great
questions from the audience i'm so sorry
we haven't had a chance to get through
them all i'm going to try and squeeze in
one a very quick one for jamie before we
we finish and that's just um from julia
who asks did you foresee how freedom of
speech would be abused online when you
first became interested in the internet
that's how the dream ends
no i suppose i suppose i was um i was
very i i've been just like reading loads
of like john stuart mill and being all
like oh the marketplace of ideas and the
sort of clashing of free ideas leads to
a synthesis it'll be fantastic and it
gives voice to
a lot of um
a lot of people a lot of
sort of previously underserved or
under-heard communities who finally get
their chance to get you know and i think
most of us we talked about it before the
the live button was hit that how we all
thought we all thought that and we may
be all slightly naive about how that
could be manipulated by powerful people
and powerful forces for lots of reasons
so i i definitely didn't know i
definitely didn't force i definitely
didn't foresee that at all
so with that sense of
the dream being curdled um i'm afraid
we've completely run out of time but
thank you so much to tonight's guests to
jamie bartlett david babs and margaret
hodge and thanks to intelligent squared
for hosting this event and thanks to
everyone who's tuned in we've had some
brilliant questions i'm so sorry we ran
out of time to get through them all but
do carry on the debate online hashtag
iq2 thanks again